[Music]
hey
okay so a lot of you have asked about
safety
uh is it safe to live on the road in a
vehicle
in a van um is it safe as a female to
travel
what about traveling solo as a female
these are all great questions
maybe you're interested in trying out
this lifestyle
maybe you know someone who is or maybe
you think this is absolutely crazy
um maybe you've watched way too many
horror movies
today i want to share my perspective on
safety as a solo female traveler
and also share some tips and tricks that
have helped me
and will hopefully be helpful for you
alright so i just want to start off by
saying that
i live on the road in a van by myself
by choice i want that to be clear
because there are people who live
in a vehicle out of necessity and not by
choice
when i was growing up i lived in a car
with my mom for
a time we didn't live in a car because
we wanted to but because we had to
and you know i'm sure that was really
hard on her because when things
felt unsafe or it was maybe a bad
situation
she didn't necessarily have the
resources to remove us from those
situations
ideally if you are going to pursue this
lifestyle you have a little bit of money
tucked away so that
if things get hard or you find yourself
in a bad situation
you can rent a hotel or an airbnb or
maybe even scrap the whole plan
and go rent an apartment i choose this
lifestyle because it allows me to travel
and be in the places that i love and do
what i love and it actually really
benefits my career because
i'm an outdoor adventure photographer
and being able to
spend the night not too far from a
trailhead or
you know like a new location uh really
helps me create new content
in an easier way rather than commuting
back and forth from an apartment
all the time you know i tried that it
was not very efficient
or fun to do so i just want to put that
out there
that those are two very different things
choosing this lifestyle on your own
terms or choosing it out of necessity
now the big question is it safe
i want to ask you something do you feel
safe right now
like in this moment wherever you are
with the people you're with
completely entirely safe
i have experienced one break-in and i've
been living in my vehicle for two plus
years
and that break-in happened when i was
living in a house
10 years ago i've had two vehicles
stolen
once from right outside my apartment
where it's parked
and another time in a gated community
with 24-hour surveillance
like an actual guard safety is never
really guaranteed
we all come into this world the same way
we all leave it the same way we die
that's that's how it goes whether or not
you choose to limit yourself based on
fear
and where that line is is entirely up to
you
so what are some things you can do to
minimize risk i'm going to start with
the most controversial topic uh which
could be a whole nother episode and
probably will be but parking some of the
resources i use are
freecampsites.net and the app
i overlander i'm typically spending the
night on blm land bureau of land
management
national forest land and
campsites i also stay in walmart parking
lots when it's allowed or
a rest area or sometimes residential
neighborhoods though i really try to
avoid that
um there are a lot of other options out
there
some are very gray some are arguably not
okay so like i said controversial
but it's really important that if you do
park and you're set up for the night and
then you get like a funny feeling that
you act on that you leave
like don't take chances okay this is
super basic but i'm gonna say it anyway
lock your doors uh sometimes it's easy
enough to forget when you're on the
inside of the van
and put up privacy curtains if you have
them
i have magnetic covers that go on all my
windows and i also have a blackout
curtain that i shut completely so
unless someone has been paying really
close attention to me and i've been
getting in and out of my van it's hard
for them to know who's in this van
and how many people are in this van
don't draw attention to yourself
so this kind of plays off of what i just
said but you don't want to be
going in and out of the van
unnecessarily and like setting up lawn
chairs
and just being very visible in a place
where you are
potentially unsafe you know if you're
out in the middle of nowhere
and there aren't people around you or
you can generally
get a feel for what's going on around
you like of course
live your life but if you're in an urban
area and it's not your space to be
spreading out and like running around
like you own the place
you're like in some walmart parking lots
people just put out their awning they
put out their chairs they put out their
coolers they cook dinner and
you know you can do whatever you want i
guess it's a free country but
at the same time if you're a solo female
traveler you might want to think twice
unfortunately change the wi-fi hotspot
on your phone
so try to make it sound like something
intimidating or at the very least a
party of two
i can't tell you how many times i've
rolled up to blm
and there's maybe one van near me and i
can immediately see their wi-fi when i
go to sign on
and it's something just really
uh obvious you know like
what's a good example um
cat mom i don't know just like maybe
change it to something that isn't
too obvious that it's like a female in
there anyway that's just my two cents
don't let your phone die this is your
lifeline to the outside world let
someone know where you are at all times
so in this case uh i do google location
sharing with my mom
and she knows where i am all the time
and if
for some reason i'm not moving for a
good amount of time she's super rad she
checks in
and that leads me to my next point which
is
share a password with that person so
let's say my mom sees that i've been in
the same place for a little while and
she asks
why and if i'm okay well worst case
scenario here
but if i've been taken hostage they take
my phone sign in with my password and
they're trying to reply to make it seem
like everything's okay
my mom is going to ask for a password
she wants to confirm that it's me
so we have a password between the two of
us that she'll ask for
and if said kidnapper is asking or is
trying to act on my behalf
he or she is not gonna know that
password so
uh that tips my mom off right away that
something is
not right self defense
this one is super obvious um i'm not
gonna tell you what methods i have
or use because the element of surprise
is honestly
one of your biggest assets in a
threatening situation
there are a lot of possibilities here
firearms bear spray pepper spray
bow and arrow baseball bat bb gun
machete hatchet taser taekwondo
booby traps ninja stars brass knuckles
unhinged lagoon mount basically a
baseball bat empty wine bottle
like smash it use it seriously don't
take this lightly
keep weapons peppered throughout your
vehicle and know how to use them
so imagine different scenarios what if
an attacker
gets into your van and ties you up
throws you in the back and drives away
like
you want to make sure you have a knife
stored in the back so that you can cut
yourself loose hopefully
um what if a meth head breaks into your
van when you're sleeping and climbs on
top of you in the middle of the night
make sure that you have a weapon
right there accessible and one that's
going to do some damage another thing to
keep in mind
is it's a good idea to have your phone
within arm's reach that's your lifeline
to call emergency services
or someone who can come help you and
also
you might want to keep something near
you that can make a lot of noise
so a whistle a foghorn let's say someone
is loitering outside of your vehicle
and you just have like a really weird
feeling about it what i would do in that
situation
is i would put on a hoodie i would hide
my hair just so it's not super obvious
that i'm a girl by myself
climb up into the front seat i would
start the car turn on the headlights
if the person doesn't go away and i feel
threatened i would maybe even lay on the
horn
um just something to send the very clear
message
that you're aware that they're out there
and then of course just drive away
don't take chances there are so so many
things you can do
to protect yourself um there's no reason
why just because you're a female or solo
traveler
that you can't level the playing field
in a bad situation
um i highly recommend having a arsenal
of weapons at your disposal honestly i'm
not joking like i have a lot
you gotta decide what you are
comfortable with and
and be mindful of how you approach
different situations
and i just want to say probably the best
best method of defense is just to avoid
bad situations altogether
what can really make a difference is
your awareness level and
how you're presenting yourself in a
potentially vulnerable situation
so for example when you're walking down
the street
are you staring down at your phone are
you
fully engaged in a phone conversation
when you leave
the store and it's late at night and
you're going to your vehicle
are you fumbling around for half a
minute looking for your keys in your
purse in the dark
or are you already ready to get in the
car and go if i'm passing through
an unfamiliar town and i'm say
at a gas station or a grocery store and
i feel
this honestly i can't even think of an
example where this has happened
but it's just so rare but if someone
were to be taking a little too much
interest in me
or kind of i feel like i'm being
followed a little bit
um i would just hang back and wait you
know like i wouldn't walk out to my
vehicle because i don't want to
associate myself
with my vehicle and that really just
comes down to being aware of what's
going on around you
another thing to consider is when you're
getting into your van or your vehicle
it's helpful to get into the front
driver's side
rather than if you have a converted van
or whatever opening the big sliding door
just kind of advertises like hey world i
leave
live in my car or i'm traveling in my
car and i have a lot of things in here
so i whenever possible try to get into
the driver's side
another small thing just when you park
it's a good idea to always face your
exit
so that if you do have to peel out of
there you can
easily and also like before you go to
sleep putting stuff away
so that if you have to hop in the front
seat stuff's not flying all over the
place you don't have your
your vehicle or your van fairly secure
and just ready to go if a stranger walks
up to me
and i'm alone and i'm potentially
distracted like i have arms full of
groceries or something
i am already going to have my guard up
as a solo female
if that person starts asking me
questions like oh
do you live in your van do you sleep in
your van like where are you going where
do you stay i don't understand like
what kind of places allow you to sleep
in your van
um they could be put they could be
completely harmless
but i am already going to be very like
guarded in replying to those con those
questions because
i don't want a stranger knowing where
i'm going to sleep or whether or not i
live in a van
by myself because i could potentially
make myself into a target
especially as a photographer i have a
lot of gear in here so
i'm just super mindful of that and
honestly
like the only people that need to know
where you're going to spend the night
specifically are like
your person that knows where you are at
all times unless you're traveling with
friends and you're trying to coordinate
with them
um otherwise it's just not information
that you should be
sharing broadly in my opinion so the
same logic extends to dms emails
instagram stories any kind of social
media really
um i generally share to my social media
a day two days sometimes a week or even
later
after i've left just to protect my
privacy
and my actual location so unless you're
a really good friend i've met you in
person or you can be vouched for
through friends of friends like i'm
neither confirming nor denying my
location if you
ask and i just think that's a good rule
of thumb for anyone
regardless of whether or not you live in
a car i realize that
that can come across as super unfriendly
at times
but you know for me personally i'd much
rather be
unfriendly than potentially put myself
in a bad situation with a stranger
trust your gut trust your intuition
don't take chances
um do your research there are challenges
and risks associated with this lifestyle
absolutely um just like any other kind
of living
you know like if you let fear live your
life you're gonna miss out on some
really beautiful experiences
but if you aren't mindful of what you're
doing you're gonna end up in some really
bad situations
so i just think like anything in life it
requires a little bit of balance
and for me personally this has been an
overwhelmingly
positive experience i've been on the
road for two plus years i've traveled
quite a bit by myself and i just i can't
recommend it enough
there's so much personal growth you
really push your limitations you find
out
what you're capable of and where your
weaknesses and strengths lie
and it's just it's a really beautiful
way to grow as a person
and to open your mind to other cultures
and ways of life and perspectives
a lot of you might disagree with this
and that's totally okay this is just my
opinion
i personally have traveled through 36
countries and i've lived in five and at
least
half of that time i was completely alone
as
a solo female traveler if you found this
video helpful
please like and subscribe i'll be
working on another video for you guys
soon
i'm thinking about covering how i make
money on the road
um just working remotely and what i do
for a living
if you think that's a good topic if you
would find that useful
let me know in the comments below um as
well as other potential topics
until then i'll be practicing my high
kicks
and ninja star throwing skills stay safe
out there